here now Jonathan gilam he's a former
FBI agent and US Navy SEAL so there's a
little confusion now what do you think's
happening
tactically well I think it's it's hurry
up and pause is what you will see right
here at this point is that uh because
darkness is there darkness is their
friend now and also the extent of time
that's passed since the uh the actual
attack occurred yesterday uh this
individual if he is in that house he
could have food in there which gives him
food but he's not going to be able to
rest and so they have time on their
hands if he is in in the house but
earlier as you all were talking about um
it's important for them not to solely
focus on this house because that's how
individuals end up getting away um but
Jesse can I just say one thing about
what Dana was saying there that's very
very important is that um every day in
this country people are uh they interact
with law enforce en forcement on a
violent scale but not violent enough to
where they are arrested law enforcement
will allow them to go and who they are
and what they have done and their
behavior that is uh displayed is never
charted and a lot of these individuals
are repeat offenders at that level over
and over and over again when you take
that type of an individual that is not
charted you throw in their mental health
um and people don't take the mental
health seriously what you're seeing is
in all of these people who do mass
shootings this is a characteristic that
is over and over and over again
displayed to law enforcement but none of
that information is ever collected and
what I would like to see is a database
that when police officers interact with
people just like you would do on your
phone when you get a little
questionnaire and you just put in there
the basic uh behaviors of this
individual if there was mental issues
you to start tabulating some of this
Intelligence on these people because you
can't just let it fly by it looks like
we're seeing a lot of the vehicles
depart the residence I saw about a dozen
Vehicles some armored some regular squad
cars leaving this guy's residence that
tells me there is no one there maybe the
search is over maybe they went in we
didn't see it again that's right on top
of the hill so it's very hard to tell
exactly what went down on the property
but again these are a lot of vehicles
leaving the house that is owned by this
suspect so they may have made entry and
there's nothing there um also there's
also during the initial uh sound that
goes out or call that goes out that that
there may be someone in the house you're
going to see a tremendous amount of law
enforcement come to that location but
after a period of time that is wasted
Manpower that could be out searching so
it could be a combination of either one
of those things yeah because we heard I
think before is one of these towns only
has 17 officers and this is a very very
lowd density state I mean it's very very
low population and the population is all
along the coast and once you get North
once you get West it's all
Woods right and one of the things that
nobody saw about is how long it took to
get the law enforcement uh presence
going I mean there was a lot of time
between the the initial attack the
second attack
and then when the call went out to the
locals uh to shelter in place we're
we're talking about over an hour so um
that shows you the size of law
enforcement in that area it's not big so
when they responded um there I don't
know how many officers they had there
they may not have had enough to go to
both places and and once they get tied
into that investigation it gives that
individual more time to flee but one
thing I do want to say about this type
of individual is that almost 100% of the
time they there's there's only two
outcomes they're either Psychopathic and
they want to be caught because they want
the fame or they are an actual a
suicidal person um or some kind of
psychopath that wants to die and so they
end up killing themselves chances are
this individual could be dead somewhere
and we don't know that uh but again they
can't act on that they have to act on
the fact that he's still a threat wow he
could be dead somewhere I never even
considered that yeah thank you so much
we got a run thank you so much Jonathan
you got it Jesse hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else